here today the pirates and the cubs it
is opening day and we've got fans in the
house we're ready to roll starting
pitcher for the cubs to uh battle the
pittsburgh pirates here this afternoon
is kyle hendricks kee brian hayes who
hit 376 this
last year and 4 31 this spring
brian hayes drives one to deep left
field and keep ryan hayes on opening day
it's a two-run homer
how do you like this kid
he did that into that win that's blowing
from left to right oh baby ki bryan
hayes what a start you know and it's not
like one of those line drive type home
runs that are you know fighting to win
that is not a cheapie
and a quick quick opening day down
payment on rookie of the year yeah
eleven ball games 427 era
a lot of
strikeouts 44 and 46.
cool fires there he goes that one laced
into right center wilson around second
on his way to third polanco will pick it
up rizzo
is into second he's got a double
and the cubs are in business second and
third one out
all loaded up for jock first played
appearance as a cub
in the air left field well struck
reynolds back and makes the catch
tagging from third contreras the cubs on
the board jacques
with a sac fly it's 2-1
and pass third into left what a piece of
hitting from adam frazier
big two out hit brings home polanco
3-1 pirates
just going with the pitch
it's kind of breaking down and away
they got
you know most everybody kind of
moved over on him so he's going to go
the other way there's more open space on
that
side hendricks has had to work hard here
today
and he gets a big strikeout in that spot
polanco is gone two away
there's a one-two
gotta got him on the outside corner well
done
pitch in the dirt
now taking off contreras it goes into
center wilson will get up alfred picks
it up throw there save
aggressive base running from wilson
contreras
[Applause]
swing a high fly ball right field
polanco towards the corner makes the
grab tagging from third
and in the score is contreras
and anthony rizzo gets the cubs within a
run
[Music]
[Applause]
3-2 ball game here is the former cub
dwayne underwood junior against zach
davies
a swing and a miss yeah how about that
yes only that one 94. he popped that one
a little bit back to back strikeouts for
dwayne underwood
wow what an inning huh about it
it's wayne underwood junior
can't be more impressive than that
and stallings with a fly ball toward
left field and over the head of peterson
cora will wave one
the throw to the plate won't get him
ball gets away but not far enough for
newman to think about trying to score so
how about jacob stallings now how about
that at bat the way he just
fought and fought and fought
oh ah dandy from
sam howard it's like sammy
four fastballs three of them
around the edges but on the plate
and the one that wasn't on the plate
missed by maybe an inch or two
right on by 94.
wow
back-to-back strikeouts
but what i'm telling you is yeah that's
just he just tore those guys up yeah i'm
not going to stay away
oh what do i know
i thought he fouled it but he didn't
nice inning geez
sam howard strikes out the side one two
three
this ball hit toward left center field
and drops in and past center
adam frazier what a day
opening day for adam frazier he doubles
in a run
and the pirates lead 5-2
it's hard to stay hot when it's cold
like this but frazier's doing it and
again just continuing what we saw from
him all spring training all he does is
hit
gets a little fastball up out over the
plate
and
thought it might stay in the air too
long but it's almost maybe like that
wind helped that thing get down landing
perfectly between the left and
center fielder
and frazier
maybe didn't have to dive head first but
did it
they're within three
right field polanco
[Music]
third sac fly of the day as sogar comes
in and the cubs back within two
hey last ups for the cubs they trail the
pirates five to three richard rodriguez
the shields numbers for him
last season
very good
and the pirates
have led the whole way
and now jack
picks up the walk
[Applause]
in the dirt that gets past stallings
down to second is peterson wild pitch
[Applause]
that's there
oh
how about that comeback
in this scenario you've got to have them
covered
there they are there they're surprised
yeah
little four-seam fastball but they got a
tail on it because he kind of flops his
wrist out a little bit get a little side
spin so that run back to the strike zone
and he gets it raise the jolly roger
[Music]
the bucks on opening day
defeat the chicago cubs
absolutely fantastic work by the bullpen